you know I hate drama but apparently
this drama has exploded to the point
that a channel as undramatic as mine has
to monetize from and even though my
knowledge is tenuous at best and this
all originated from a Twitter user with
negative two followers I have to say
this stop talking about the drama this
is on everyone who's feeding into the
drama
except for me because because I hate it
oh I just I hate drow a big streamer
were to react to my take on the drama
that would be
bad because I hate drama but if people
were to talk about drama in the comment
section of this video that would be fine
because they know I hate drama and if
you were to watch all 13 mid rolls on
this eight minute and one second video
that would be fine too because I had if
you're ordering McDonald's and your
friend says